- My big thing
is that I genuinely
don't think most things matter.
And so, I'm very
big on lack of ego is
why I'm good at delegating.
I actually think way too many
people suck at delegating 'cause
they're egotistical and they don't
deploy enough humility and they
actually are micromanaging out
of their own insecurities and so
it's very easy for me
to delegate because
I trust people and
I trust them up front.
My dad always says, "You got
to earn my trust," and I always
say, "I'm giving you
trust and you gotta lose it and
"actually it's
kind of hard to lose."
I think that's
allowed me to go fast.
It's allowed me to scale.
I think it's a differentiator
and I don't think anything can
really cripple me and
so I give them the room.
I think delegation
has a lot to do
with ego and insecurities and
I watch and am able to do a lot
of things by giving people room
and to me if
I'm doing 97 things
and 97 people are helping me
and they're all ranging from if
a 10 was perfect execution from
a 4.2 to a 9.7 doing 97 things
from a 4.2 to 9.7 is a hell of a
lot better than doing
one or two things a 10.0.
It's a net score game and that's
how I'm wired and that's how
I strategize and then as people
prove that they can do 9.2,
8.7 work I move them up and
if they prove
they can do 11.0 work,
I remind them that
they maybe should be doing
something up for themselves.
That's the bottom line.
(light music)